yeah I know welcome to this video yeah
I'm posting this because of a special
thing that happened on my channel
yesterday I got a challenge there
bye-bye viewer I said the hello tuck is
German for hello basically or good day
on three challenges for you um um with
black here don't play the Royal pass no
d5 against you for no names or Indian
booger in your no Kings Indian for two
days um challenge to was playing the
pond siani with white till you won at
least two games okay this will be tricky
to finish that in two days if I get that
right i mean I playing six games on two
days yeah like three games on today so
I'm not quite sure how this is going to
work and that one is no default system
with white for two days I think default
system probably includes an idea three
and maybe even one c4 so I guess it's a
four or other obscure moves if I it's
not obscure but like let's say be three
or before or whatever um yeah yeah
please choose one then the channel will
get more interesting yeah I already
responded to that um but you did not yet
reply to that um actually i modified the
idea and saying okay what about doing
this for one week and doing that with
the poinciana that that makes sense
maybe I try to play the poinciana for
what for a week trying to win two games
with that hmm yeah okay what I'm asking
you basically because some I want a bit
of a wider opinion their broader opinion
based what about stuff like that should
i do that i mean i'd like to do that
like what about one week yeah of
different things um yeah like I i would
i would avoid then e five against before
i would play I don't know what can i
play then actually against tafoya
they've been only the Dutch defense
whatever though somewhat more somewhat
more enterprising openings mmm the pond
see ally with why
hmm okay and well I would probably would
go afore most of the time because I'm
not allowed to play deform I guess
related systems yeah please give me some
feedback I actually what I have to add
is that if i do that so I've a good
positive feedback on the idea and I
wrote here um I have pre produced lots
of videos because i'm on a longer
vacation I'm starting um in June so on I
have pre-scheduled weeks of stuff so if
this is going to be on it will be an um
mid late June so I don't cannot now do
this and reschedule everything that is
already entered into YouTube this is
like now I cannot do that it just takes
ages to get this changed so if I'm going
to do that it would be something unlike
mid late June yeah please give me some
feedback I like those kind of challenges
it's it's fun yeah thanks for watching